jamais un premier ministre britannique
n'avait tenu si peu de temps avant de
s'avancer à ce fameux pupitre pour jeter
l'éponge j'espère que tous les gens si
on nomme Street et bien j'espère que ça
valait le coup j'espère que ça en valait
la peine au moins pour les affaires
courantes parce que le mal qu'ils ont
fait à notre partie est extraordinaire
étant donné la situation je ne peux pas
remplir le mandat pour lequel j'ai été
élu par le Parti conservateur
du Parti conservateur ce qui a provoqué
la chute de listroth c'est la
présentation d'un plan économique de
croissance qui a viré au fiasco un plan
de baisse massif d'impôts et un soutien
colossal facture énergétique qui a fait
craindre aux banques un dérapage des
comptes publics j'ai eu l'occasion à
plusieurs reprises de rencontrer
l'histoire et nous avons encore échangé
cette semaine et ça devient une relation
de travail qui se qui se construisait et
je souhaite que en tout cas la
Grande-Bretagne puisse trouver le plus
rapidement possible la stabilité elle
est de l'avance et c'est bon pour nous
et c'est bon pour notre Europe et en
coulisses loin des camarades et c'est
plutôt tendu la relation
franco-allemande est exécrable va même
jusqu'à dire un député allemand le
couple franco-allemand n'existe plus
bien participant de l'une de leurs
rencontres si l'Union européenne
plafonne le prix du gaz il y a un risque
que les producteurs vantailleurs et que
nous nous retrouvions avec moins de gaz
au lieu de plus
c'est pourquoi l'Europe doit se
coordonner avec d'autres consommateurs
comme le Japon et la Corée afin de ne
pas se concurrencer les uns les autres
et puis au lave Scholl sa tendance à
faire cavalier seul à prendre des
décisions sans même avertir le président
français il a lancé par exemple un plan
de relance pour son seul pays avec une
somme colossale 200 milliards d'euros
sans même prévenir Paris je pense que ce
n'est pas bon ni pour l'Allemagne ni
pour l'Europe quel s'isole et donc il
est important que sur une des
propositions qui font l'objet d'un assez
large consensus qu'on puisse trouver une
unanimité ça agace beaucoup forcément
mais ça inquiète aussi une source
française lâche au Figaro les Allemands
veulent nous écraser un lion blessé à la
merci de deuxiènes affamés cette scène
s'est déroulée dans le parc national de
Kruger en Afrique du Sud alors que la
menace se rapproche le lion voit au loin
son sauveur de Monsieur Mélenchon qui
vous l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure me
traitée psychopathe ce qui montre
le niveau des arguments il n'y a pas de
violence systémique mais il y a des
moments où il y a de la violence faut
pas se le cacher et je dis même dans ce
bouquin que la violence est absolument
partout le pachyme vole au secours du
fauve diminuer en faisant fuir les
deuxiènes un soutien de poids pour le
roi de la savane contente du
gouvernement on est là pour rendre des
comptes et pour répondre aux questions
qui sont posées ce qui est indécent en
revanche c'est la récupération politique
l'instrumentalisation politique de la
mémoire de cette fillette par certaines
formations politiques notamment à
l'extrême droite ceux qui ne sont pas
des sons c'est ceux qui justement
cyniquement
instrumentalisent la douleur de cette
famille pour pouvoir se défausser de
leur responsabilité et pour fuir le
débat l'accusation de récupération c'est
une accusation qui est utilisée de
manière systématique par le gouvernement
pour étouffer les questions légitimes
que doivent poser les oppositions le
gouvernement je me suis exprimé
complètement sur ce que je pensais je ne
vais pas alimenter une machine qui pour
moi est une machine obscène voilà
Monsieur et les deux parties ont chacun
organiser des rassemblements un premier
à eu lieu place d'enfer au choix Paris à
l'Institut pour la Justice une
association réputée proche de l'examen
et de son parti reconquête le RN a opté
pour une minute de silence devant
l'Assemblée nationale enfin d'après-midi
câlin pour ceux qui ont de la peine le
message inscrit sur un panneau au cœur
de Téhéran de femmes sans foulard
prennent des passants dans leurs bras